i want to start with some good news
let's have a look at the picture for
excess deaths
in the uk it's been a very depressing
shot we've shown you it for many months
now comparing this this white line here
which is the
historic level of deaths uh in the uk
over different weeks of the year
with what's happened during this
pandemic and you can make out that very
big spike we had
uh last spring going up and to where we
have this
increase so you can see the second wave
there but if you come
a little bit closer you can probably
just make out look that black line
is now below the white line and what
does that mean it means that that second
period
that second wave of mortality now may
well be
at an end and that seems like a good
moment to reflect on what we're talking
about on how many people
have died of this virus when you have a
look at this the number of deaths with
covid on the certificate
um well they are two very big increases
and if you add up all of those numbers
um we are talking about 149 thousand
and deaths with covert 19 on the
certificate
a terrifying number and if you look at
when those deaths took place whether
they were in the first wave
or in the second wave well there's a
striking comparison here i'll turn those
into bars
so you can compare the height of them
and look that first wave is actually a
lot lower 57 58 000
deaths in the first wave 91 000 in the
second wave so the second wave
far worse when it comes to this official
covert 19
death toll but there's a different way
of measuring it if you look just at
excess depth it's a slightly different
picture those bars actually
go the other way around and the first
wave is slightly bigger than the second
wave why is that
because potentially in this second wave
particularly over the winter period
some people who might have died of other
diseases may well have died
of covert 19. so that's why there's a
difference potentially between those two
measures
but a lot of people have asked about
international comparisons is the uk the
worst in the world when it comes
to mortality well not quite but it's
certainly not that promising a picture
these bars show you the higher they are
the more deaths there are per person so
it's population adjusted in all these
different countries
so you've got czech republic in belgium
at the top there's the uk in sixth place
but it's worth saying this isn't
comprehensive there are some countries
which don't reflect
uh all of their covered 19 deaths uh
very well don't report them very well
and if you look at excess death so again
historical versus where we are this year
it's a different picture you look you've
got peru and russia moving to the top
there
and the uk in 16th place rather than
sixth place
now some might see that as a good
outcome but it's worth just reflecting
that bar could have been so much lower
than that